social network hungry Brazilians are
being targeted with disinformation some
of it too ludicrous to believe
and yet many people do
from claims that incumbent candidate
bolsonaro and his rival Lula da Silva
have made pacts with the devil and
satanic Cults to unsubstantiated claims
that bolsonaro is a pedophile and that
Lula has ordered churches to be burned
down fact Checkers in Brazil can't keep
up
a nationwide Coalition of investigative
journalists is fighting disinformation
and helping Brazil's electoral Court
identify it
another Montage uses an unidentified
voice to say that Lula ordered this boat
destroyed because the owners hadn't
voted for him in the first round
this one uses an old interview with
bolsonaro taken out of context to claim
that he's a cannibal
the Electoral court has banned at least
500 social media posts for quote
knowingly sharing and distributing
untrue or Gravely decontextualized
information
on this day alone fact Checkers here are
analyzing 1600 dubious Tick Tock
postings
it's important to say that while there's
more disinformation spread from the
bolsonaro camp there is disinformation
on both sides
indeed both sides are playing dirty
spreading disinformation into just about
every household
Lula has been struggling to shake a
social media slander campaign claiming
he's a drug trafficker this after a
recording of a leader of South America's
largest drug cartel the PCC was leaked
suggesting he supported Lula's campaign
our request for clarification from
lawyers representing leaders of the PCC
were denied but sources that are close
to the criminal Syndicate tell us that
they don't pick sides during national
elections only local ones as for the
video it turned out to be from 2019 and
was clearly manipulated and so the
Electoral court ordered that it be
removed but only after it had spread
like wildfire
Bolson Auto supporters are accusing the
Electoral Court judges of censorship
but disinformation expert Alexandre
Pacheco disagrees
they're trying to to actually
fight against these in my view this
harmful phenomenon because this
information could actually not only
influence uh voters but can actually
lead us to uh episodes of violence
violence that has already shown its ugly
face while this information fuels the
most polarized election campaign in
Brazil's history Lucia Newman Al Jazeera
Sao Paulo